what we have here is a molecular
equation describing the reaction
of some sodium chloride dissolved in
water plus some silver silver nitrate
also dissolved in the water they're
going to react to form sodium nitrate
still dissolved in water plus
solid
silver chloride and if you were to look
at each of these compounds in their
crystalline or solid form before they're
dissolved in water they each look like
this but once you get dissolved in water
and that's what this aqueous form tells
us it tells us that each of these
compounds are going to get dissolved in
water they're no longer going to be in
that crystalline form crystalline form
instead you're going to have the
individual ions disassociating so for
example in the case of sodium chloride
the sodium is going to disassociate in
the water sodium is a positive ion or a
cation and so it's going to be attracted
to the partially negative oxygen end
remember oc water is a is a polar
molecule that's what makes it such a
good solvent
now the chloride anions similarly are
going to dissolve in water because
they're going to be attracted to the
partially positive hydrogen ends of the
water molecules and the same thing is
going to be true of the silver nitrate
silver the silver ion once it's
disassociated is going to be positive
and the nitrate is a negative it is an
anion
now in order to appreciate this
and and write an equation that better
conveys this this the dissociation of
the ions we could instead write the
equation like this
this makes it a little bit clearer that
look the sodium and the chloride aren't
going to be necessarily together anymore
the sodium is going to dissolve in the
water like we have here the chloride is
going to dissolve in the water the
silver ions are going to dissolve in the
water and so is so are the nitrate ions
so this makes it a little bit clearer
and similarly on this end with the
sodium nitrate stays dissolved so we can
write it like this with the individual
ions disassociated but the silver
chloride is in solid form you could
think of it as precipitating out of the
solution this is not this does not have
a high solubility so it's not going to
get dissolved in the water and so we
still have it in solid form
now you might say well which of these is
better well it just depends what you are
trying to go for
this form up here which we see more
typically this is
just a standard molecular equation
molecular
molecular
equation it's in balanced form we always
want to have our
our equations balanced this right over
here is known as a complete ionic
equation the completes there because we
put in all of the ions and we're going
to compare it to a net ionic equation in
a second complete ionic
equation sometimes just known as an
ionic equation now why is it called that
well because we're showing the
individual ions as they're disassociated
in water
now what would a net ionic equation be
well let's think about that a little bit
let me free up some space
so we
one thing that you notice on both sides
of this complete ionic equation you have
the same ions that are disassociated in
water so for example on the left hand
side you have the sodium that's
dissolved in water and you also have on
the right hand side sodium dissolved in
in the water it's not if you think about
the silver chloride being the thing
that's being produced this thing is in
ionic form and dissolved form on both
sides of this reaction and so you could
view it as a spectator and that's
actually what it's called it's called a
spectator ion
spec
spectator
ion if you want to think of it in human
terms it's kind of
out there and watching the reaction
happen its value in this reaction is
well it was part of the sodium chloride
and it's provided so the sodium chloride
is is providing the chloride that
eventually forms the silver chloride but
the sodium is is just kind of watching
similarly
you have the nitrate the nitrate is
dissolved on the left and the nitrate is
dissolved on the right so the nitrate is
also a spectator ion so if you want to
go from a complete ionic equation to a
net ionic equation which really deals
with the things that aren't
that aren't spectators
well you just get rid of the spectator
ions so you get rid of that you get rid
of that you get rid of that you get rid
of that and then you see what is left
over well what we have left over is we
have some
dissolved chloride
and we write aqueous to show that it is
dissolved plus some dissolved silver
plus some
dissolved silver once again
to show that it's dissolved we write
aqueous
and if you put those two together you
are going to get some
solid silver
solid silver chloride
all right
and what's useful about this form it's
it's one it's more compact and it's very
clear what is actually
reacting what is being used to build and
you can say hey however you get your
chloride into the solution however you
get your silver into the solution this
is the these are the things that are
going to react to form the solid instead
of using sodium chloride maybe you use
potassium chloride and the potassium in
that case would be a spectator ion and
but either way your net ionic equation
would be what we have here